le 17 rue de Tivoli n'est plus qu'un
amas de ruines sur un terrain difficile
d'accès c'est entre les immeubles
voisins que cette pince a pu se faufiler
pour soulever des tonnes de gravats les
recherches se déroulent avec avec
prudence puisque
l'espoir de retrouver des survivants et
toujours présents balai macabre depuis
ce matin ou des corps sans vie sont
extraits des décombres la course contre
la montre pour retrouver de potentiels
survivants et lancés mais l'espoir
demeure et nous avons la possibilité de
trouver des survivants probablement des
survivants il faut garder cet espoir
rien n'est sûr rien n'est évident on
peut pas raconter n'importe quoi ça fait
partie bien évidemment des pistes
l'explosion au gaz puisque c'est une
explosion qu'on amène à une extrême
violence notre drame survenu hier
également cette fois-ci dans le massif
du Mont Blanc une avalanche qui a
emporté plusieurs personnes un crocodile
a décidé de prendre en chasse l'animal
à quelques mètres du rivage le reptile
tente une attaque
belle défense du cervidé qui a
vaillamment refusé d'être le plat du
jour il s'agit de skieur qui ont été
pris dans cette coulée de neige il
participait à une randonnée sur une voie
classique du massif le temps était bon
il n'y avait pas d'alerte particulière
les victimes sont donc deux guides
autres montagnes et 4 de leur client
l'exercice aura duré trois longs jours
12 navires de guerre 91 avions chinois
depuis samedi la Chine simulée des
frappes et encerclés Taïwan l'exercice
militaires sont menés au large de
pington un territoire chinois distant de
seulement 125 km de Taipei sur les 71
avions militaires repérés autour de
l'île 45 confranchi la ligne médiane du
détroit faisant office de frontières
Emmanuel Macron il disait très
clairement deux jours qu'il ne voulait
pas prendre parti ça ne ferait
qu'accentuer les tensions dit-il donc on
fait quoi qu'elle doit être la position
de l'Europe dans ce conflit on reste
neutre cela fait suite à la rencontre
entre la évidente taïwanaise et une
délégation de parlementaires américains
ce que Pékin a dénoncé considérant que
Taïwan ne devait pas avoir
d'indépendance diplomatique espérons que
la communauté internationale reconnaîtra
pleinement la vérité sur la question de
Taïwan qu'elle respectera fermement le
principe d'une seule Chine et qu'elle
s'opposera fermement à toutes les formes
d'activité séparatistes liées à
l'indépendance de Taïwan avec
l'indépendance de Taïwan la paix et la
stabilité dans le détroit sont exclus
ces dernières années nous avons été
confrontés à un expansionnisme
autoritaire continue la coopération avec
les démocraties est devenue plus
importante je tiens à réaffirmer que le
peuple taïwanais aime la démocratie et
recherche la paix il considère que
Taïwan fait partie de la Chine en ce qui
concerne l'Europe là aussi les choses
sont très claires
l'Europe est pour pour le maintien du
statu quo nous devons poursuivre les
ventes d'armes à Taïwan et veiller à ce
que ces armes arrivent dans les
meilleurs délais
notre objectif fait que l'hypothèse
d'une guerre ne se réalise jamais ce que
nous enseigne l'histoire et que la
meilleure façon d'y parvenir cette
fournir des armes pour permettre aux
gens de se défendre le secrétaire
national sortant du PCF a été réélu ce
midi avec plus de 80 % des voix le
député du Nord avait ouvert ce congrès à
Marseille vendredi en déclarant aux
voies critique notamment de la France
insoumise mais les vous de vos Affaires
à 53 ans Fadia Roussel se vit plus que
jamais comme un électron libre gloire
aux éboueurs aux Reaper que Macron
remercie de leurs efforts en leur
imposant honteusement deux années de
travail supplémentaires dalaï-lama
présente ses excuses après une séquence
dérangeante filmée il y a un mois en
Inde à darhamsala lors d'une cérémonie
un jeune garçon lui demande un câlin ce
que le dalaï-lama accepte avant d'aller
plus loin et de lui faire un bisou sur
la bouche puis de lui demander de sucer
sa langue l'enfant résiste un moment
gênant écoutez ceux qui nous gouvernent
qui vivent dans les salons dorés de leur
ministère il ne tiendrait pas deux
heures derrière une benne et ils leur
font la leçon tous les jours